[Musique]
selon une récente étude qui a été
réalisée dans une dizaine de pays dont
la France
45% des jeunes de 16 à 25 ans souffre
déco anxiété tous ces émotions
désagréables liées aux réchauffement
climatique à ce sentiment de fatalité
face à ce réchauffement climatique
est-ce que les médias
comme par exemple la télé la radio la
presse écrite on leur part de
responsabilité dans la naissance de
cette angoisse contemporaine c'est fort
probable est-ce que les réseaux sociaux
comme Instagram Tik Tok Facebook peuvent
nous aider à traverser cette crise
climatique j'en suis persuadée je
m'appelle Virginie Hilson Levy je suis
journaliste spécialisée en météo climat
environnement depuis maintenant 10 ans
j'ai travaillé pour de grands médias
comme la RTBF en Belgique c'est news BFM
TV France 2 France 3
ça fait aussi 8 ans que je collabore
avec la radio Mouv qui fait partie du
groupe Radio France pour laquelle
j'anime la matinale et une chronique
aussi sur l'environnement
alors c'est vrai mon métier a beaucoup
évolué ces dernières années il y a 20
ans la météo c'était un programme lié
aux loisirs on regardait tous la météo
pour savoir qu'est-ce qu'on allait faire
ce week-end est-ce qu'on allait plus
organiser un barbecue avec les amis à
l'extérieur parce que il allait faire
beau comme on allait habiller les
enfants pour aller à l'école et puis et
puis il y a eu les tempêtes de 99 il y a
eu aussi la canicule meurtrière de 2003
il y a eu les inondations meurtrières
aussi en Europe centrale en 2005 et il y
a eu aussi et vous en avez sans doute
entendu parler de la cop21 avec ces
fameuses accords de Paris c'était en
2015 et tous les médias traditionnels et
ben ce sont tempérés du sujet on en a
entendu absolument partout que ce soit à
la télé à la radio parce que les effets
du réchauffement climatique était de
plus en plus visible et là la météo a
changé on est passé d'un programme lié
aux loisirs
le programme lié à la sécurité
aujourd'hui moi présentatrice météo je
dois répondre à ces questions pendant
que je présente la météo est-ce que
cette température qui s'affiche sur ma
carte et normale pour la saison est-ce
que c'est une normale de saison vous
avez tous entendu ça est-ce que cette
catastrophe météo qu'on est en train de
vivre ces incendies par exemple l'été
dernier est-ce que c'est lié au
réchauffement climatique et surtout
qu'est-ce que je peux faire aujourd'hui
pour me protéger on est passé d'un
programme où il y est aux loisirs à un
programme lié à la sécurité avec ses
cartes de vigilance météo que vous avez
déjà vu aussi c'est vigilance vertes
jaune orange ou encore rouge et le
réchauffement climatique c'est invité
sur les plateaux de télévision il y a
encore quelques années je faisais que
des bulletins météo et puis aujourd'hui
j'interviens dans les JT que ce soit en
direct sur les plateaux avec les
présentateurs ou que ce soit aussi sur
le terrain quand il y a une canicule ou
des inondations
alors voilà aujourd'hui personne ne peut
dire qu'il ne connaît pas l'existence de
ce réchauffement climatique les médias
font un travail formidable pour ça on en
a besoin mais le problème et vous
l'aurez sans doute aussi constaté c'est
que le message ne passe pas vraiment
alors qu'est-ce qui se passe pourquoi on
n'arrive pas à se mobiliser alors moi
qui travaille pour eux et de par mon
expérience je peux vous dire que c'est
pas totalement de leur faute en fait ils
sont ils font face à deux problématiques
la première en fait c'est de tout
simplement essayer de capter votre
attention
on va vous présenter de l'info qui est
anxiogène avec un ton anxiogène et c'est
normal parce qu'en fait plus on crée de
l'anxiété plus on a envie d'en savoir
plus plus on va rester devant son écran
ça c'est la première chose et la
première aussi c'est qu'il y a un
problème de temporalité quand je viens
et que je suis invitée sur un plateau de
télévision que ce soit sur un JT
j'interviens face à une actualité on me
laisse une minute oui on me dit dans mon
oreillette Virginie tu as une minute
pour nous dire pourquoi cette tempête
s'est formée qu'est-ce que on va faire
pour se protéger et en quoi c'est lié au
réchauffement climatique j'ai une minute
et parfois même quand je passe en fin du
JT bah j'ai 40 secondes et ça oui c'est
problématique aujourd'hui parce que ça
ne s'inscrit pas dans la manière dont on
doit parler du réchauffement climatique
qui s'inscrit lui sur un sur un temps
long et vous l'aurez constaté aussi
alors il y en a certains peu plus depuis
l'été dernier avec les incendies les
canicules il y a très peu de magazines
qui aborde le sujet
en profondeur on fait ça de manière
assez rapide alors oui je vous parlais
aussi du fait d'avoir un ton anxiogène
et ça je me souviens aussi qu'il y a un
monsieur qui m'avait envoyé un mail un
jour et qui m'avait dit et ça m'avait
marqué vous êtes bien la seule personne
que j'apprécie autant et qui m'annonce
que des mauvaises nouvelles
j'avais dit oui c'est vrai c'est vrai je
lui avais raconté c'est vrai et en fait
je me suis renseignée et je me suis dit
en fait on fait du bon travail puisque
c'était le but
et je suis tombée sur cette étude cette
étude qui dit que justement
l'information est jugée par les
personnes qui ont été interrogées
comment anxiogène à 35 % catastrophique
à 33% et moralisante à 25%
et ce jour là je me suis dit il est
temps de changer de ton
il est temps de changer notre manière
dont on parle du problème
et ce cet autre ton on peut l'aborder
tout simplement sur sur les réseaux
sociaux parce que sur les réseaux
sociaux je décide de quel sujet j'ai
envie de vous parler dans la manière
dont j'ai envie de vous parler j'ai pas
envie de vous parler par exemple
forcément de d'actu qui soit
démoralisant je peux le faire sur un ton
un peu plus positif et je peux vous
apprendre plein de choses et ça c'est ce
que j'aime le plus transmettre ce que
j'ai appris transmettre toutes mes
connaissances et surtout me dire qu'à
chaque fois que vous allez regarder une
vidéo que je fais sur les réseaux
sociaux vous avez appris quelque chose
et c'est ça qui est bien avec les
réseaux sociaux c'est que on peut faire
plein de choses on peut réinventer les
récits on peut éduquer parce que comment
finalement essayer d'accepter les
solutions qu'on nous propose qui entrave
nos libertés si on ne comprend même pas
le problème c'est quoi le problème avec
le CO2 c'est quoi le problème avec la
déforestation comment on peut faire
aujourd'hui nous à notre échelle pour
essayer de faire avancer les choses
donc on peut éduquer on peut aussi
donner de l'espoir et ça je trouve ça
très important ce que ne font pas les
médias aujourd'hui parce que j'imagine
je ne sais pas si demain vous avez un
ami qui a une grave maladie vous allez
pas lui répéter tous les jours que sa
situation est dramatique que s'il fait
rien il est foutu non vous allez essayer
de lui donner de l'espoir vous allez lui
parler de tous ces gens qui ont traversé
la même chose que lui finalement et qui
s'en sont sortis et c'est ça que j'ai
envie de faire sur les réseaux sociaux
vous dire qu'il y a des gens qui se
bougent dans le monde entier et qui ont
envie de faire avancer les choses qui
ont envie à leur échelle et qui ont fait
des choses donc on peut lui donner de
l'espoir on peut aussi apporter des
solutions parce qu'il y en a plein au
final et elles sont presque toutes
efficaces et on peut aussi bah c'est
vrai le faire sur un ton un peu plus
positif
et puis ce qui est bien aussi avec les
réseaux sociaux c'est qu'aujourd'hui à
l'heure d'Instagram à l'heure de Tik Tok
j'imagine que vous êtes tous sur les
réseaux sociaux et ben ils influencent
grandement nos comportements et ça on va
pouvoir en finir avec un mot finalement
qui fait la une de l'actualité qu'on
entend de plus en plus et qui s'appelle
l'écho anxiété c'est ce que je vous
disais tout à l'heure donc tous ces
toutes ces émotions négatives cette
anxiété face au réchauffement climatique
il y a des spécialistes aujourd'hui qui
qui vous parlent de l'écho anxiété qui
essayent de trouver des solutions face à
l'écho anxiété et comme je vous le
disais aussi il y a quand même un jeune
sur deux qui est touché par cette écho
anxiété alors oui on peut faire plein de
choses sur les réseaux sociaux ça
influence nos comportements on est passé
de suiveur d'actualité à des sueurs de
tendance de mode de vie de point de vue
et vous le savez aussi on en parle
beaucoup ce mot qui est arrivé dans
l'actualité qui qui s'appelle les
influenceurs ou les créateurs de contenu
sur les réseaux sociaux et ça il y en a
énormément aujourd'hui bien plus qu'il y
a quelques années c'est vrai que on en
compte près enfin des millions et en
fait le marché de l'influence
aujourd'hui et Ben a beaucoup beaucoup
évolué depuis toutes ces années et puis
ce qui vient aussi c'est que ces gens là
en fait et ben ils peuvent nous
mobiliser vous avez peut-être vu ces
images de ces gens qui ramassent des
bouteilles en plastique sur la plage bah
ça c'est ce qu'on appelle des échos
challenges et il y en a de plus en plus
que ce soit sur snap sur Tik Tok des
gens qui ne se connaissent pas du tout
et qui se donnent rendez-vous et c'est
l'essence même des réseaux sociaux
aujourd'hui qui se donne rendez-vous à
un endroit et qui ont décidé de tous
ensemble faire une bonne action
et là le marché de l'influence et ben il
est juste énorme parce que ses échos de
challenge il y en a beaucoup plus qui a
quelques années 150
000 influenceurs en France le marché
mondial de l'influence en 2022 c'est 15
milliards de dollars soit 20 fois plus
qu'en 2015 et donc ces personnes là sont
une partie de la solution alors je sais
ce que vous êtes en train de vous dire
mais il nous vendent un peu tout à tout
va c'est des vitrines publicitaires
c'est vrai vous avez raison mais c'est
aussi et ces personnes là sont une
grande partie de la solution mais le
problème c'est que j'ai pu échanger avec
eux parce que ça m'intéressait beaucoup
et que beaucoup m'ont dit mais Virginie
je vais pas dire que je trie mes déchets
parce qu'en fait le problème c'est que
je prends encore l'avion
l'été pour partir en vacances ou même
très souvent dans l'année quand j'ai des
déplacements donc j'ai pas envie de le
dire parce que finalement on va on va me
reprocher on va me dire je suis pas
parfait bah j'ai un scoop pour vous ce
soir personne ne l'est en fait personne
personne n'est parfait dans aucun
domaine c'est ce qu'on appelle la pureté
militante et ça c'est pas possible ça
n'existe dans vraiment aucun domaine et
je vais vous raconter une petite
histoire il y a un jour un monsieur
alors on va l'appeler Jérôme par exemple
et bien ce monsieur là il a décidé en
fait d'arrêter de prendre sa voiture le
matin pour aller au travail alors au
début il se disait bon c'était juste
parce que j'avais envie d'arriver au
travail plus rapidement j'ai toujours
des bouchons puis après il s'est dit
c'est pas mal aussi puisque finalement
moi je pollurai un peu moins
il a raison il arrivait un peu plus
rapidement au travail et en plus de ça
ce qui est bien c'est qu'il avait pas de
stress pour chercher une place de
parking donc il arrivait encore plus
rapidement et puis après plusieurs
semaines il s'est rendu compte que sa
condition physique s'améliorait il était
en meilleure santé puis il a raconté un
peu tout ça il a posté les photos de lui
avec son vélo devant son travail sur
Facebook
il en a parlé une personne et une autre
et un collègue et vous voyez ça
aujourd'hui il va ça donne une ville
comme Amsterdam qui est une des îles les
plus écolos en Europe c'est la capitale
écologique de l'Europe c'est une des
villes les plus durables du monde ça
c'était Jérôme si je vous raconte
l'histoire d'Olivier il a vraiment
existé
et bien ce monsieur un jour il a dit
j'en ai ras-le-bol d'acheter des
produits au supermarché parce que c'est
plein de pesticides il y a plein de
produits toxiques je vais aller les
acheter chez l'agriculteur du coin très
bien il est allé une fois deux fois puis
c'est rendu compte que c'était bien
meilleur ce qu'il mangeait il l'a
partagé sur les réseaux sociaux comme ça
juste pour raconter son histoire
et puis on a parlé autour de lui ayez
une autre personne qui a voulu faire la
même chose puis une autre puis une autre
et ça a donné des enseignes comme
Biocoop ou encore Naturalia ça c'est
juste un exemple deux exemples pour vous
montrer aujourd'hui que tous les gestes
que vous allez faire et ben ils ont une
influence
une énorme influence bien plus qu'on
peut on peut on peut l'imaginer
aujourd'hui il y a même des études qui
montrent aujourd'hui que nos éco-gestes
ont un potentiel de 25% de réduction de
25% des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre mais alors oui c'est vrai on n'est
pas tous suivis par des millions et des
millions de personnes peu importe vous
mettez en message et peut-être qu'il
sera vu aujourd'hui demain après-demain
peut-être qu'il sera relayé ça c'est
cool et row tweets sur Twitter les
repostes sur Instagram on repose des
stories on repose des messages et
peut-être qu'ils seront vus dans un
endroit un autre et peut-être qu'ils
seront lus un petit peu plus tard donc
ça c'est des exemples parfaits pour vous
dire que oui bah aujourd'hui un autre
échelle peu importe ce qu'on fait on
peut on peut être écolo monsieur si par
exemple vous triez vos déchets mais que
vous prenez encore votre voiture pour
aller travailler j'ai plaisir de vous
dire ce soir que vous êtes écolo
monsieur aussi si par exemple vous avez
décidé d'arrêter de manger de la viande
vous avez réduit votre consommation de
viande mais que à côté de ça c'est vrai
vous prenez encore l'avion pour partir
en vacances et ben oui vous êtes écolo
et les influenceurs aujourd'hui ou même
vous j'ai juste envie de vous dire mais
on s'en fout personne n'est là pour nous
juger qui est plus écolo qu'un autre
faites ce que vous vous avez envie de
faire partager le
et peut-être que ça touchera énormément
de monde vous êtes une grande partie de
la solution ici tout ce soir partout
et c'est hyper important aujourd'hui
d'avoir ça parce que c'est d'avoir ça
dans la tête parce que en fait au final
personne ne peut vous dire si oui vous
êtes un mauvais colo et moi je préfère
être une mauvaise écolo que de ne pas
être écolo du tout alors je sais aussi
ce que vous êtes en train de vous dire
elle est gentille mais les réseaux
sociaux il y a plein de
climatosceptiques qui partagent des
messages et oui c'est vrai ils ont aussi
une influence et pas dans le bon sens
c'est vrai je me suis intéressé
longuement au sujet j'ai regardé un peu
ce qui se disait donc tous ces gens qui
réfutent le réchauffement climatique oui
oui non mais c'est pas la cause humaine
c'est cycles naturels de la terre et
puis c'est comme ça ça a toujours existé
parce qu'une opinion elle peut être vrai
elle peut être fausse mais elle m'avance
absolument pas sur la vérité j'ai plein
de gens aussi qui m'ont dit mais tu sais
Virginie la terre est plate ah ok bah
laisse moi appeler Thomas Pesquet là
j'ai son numéro et puis on discute et on
en reparle juste après parce que lui il
l'a vu quand même la terre donc il
pourra il pourra me donner des infos là
dessus et bah c'est ça vous choisissez
vos sources d'information sur les
réseaux sociaux et moi j'ai souvent eu
quand je partage des vidéos quand je
partage des infos des gens qui me
répondent en commentaire
oui enfin tu es gentil mais ça ça
n'existe pas c'est pas c'est pas la
cause humaine non non non très bien je
réponds juste une chose à chaque fois
quelle est ta source
d'où tu me sors ça et sur quelle étude
tu t’appuies et en général et bah ça
s'arrête très vite la discussion
ça s'arrête même très très vite
alors oui il y a aussi bon c'est vrai
climato sceptique ça c'est évident et
puis je sais aussi ce que vous allez
vous êtes en train de vous dire oui mais
les réseaux sociaux la pollution
numérique ces trois quatre pour cent des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre c'est
vrai mais comme je viens de vous
l'expliquer là pendant quelques minutes
c'est un formidable terrain d'action
c'est un endroit où on peut mobiliser et
c'est un endroit où on peut dénoncer
aussi et c'est important de dénoncer ce
qui se passe parfois dans certaines
grandes entreprises certaines banques
par exemple
et s'il faut les utiliser pour dénoncer
tout ça
pour vous transmettre de l'info et ben
je le fais sans hésitation mais j'ai
envie de vous faire une promesse ce soir
je supprimerai tous mes comptes
Instagram Facebook Tik Tok snapchat
YouTube
et vous n'entendrez plus jamais parler
de moi le jour il n'y aura plus de
réchauffement climatique merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]